In this age of COVID, Americans are changing their housing habits.
Able to work from home, they are leaving crowded high-cost cities for less pricey pastures.
But even there, housing is in short supply, thanks to decades of overregulation.
Large-lot zoning makes it impossible to build small houses on small lots that cost less.
The Biden infrastructure bill includes a $5 billion plan to do something about this.
Communities that
agree to relax zoning would qualify for federal money.
It’s identified the right problem—but the plan  has its own flaws.
It takes something communities should want to do on their own and turns it into something they need to be paid to accept.
It won’t likely incentivize the wealthy locales, where housing is most restricted, to participate.
Even without aid from Washington, there’s a growing “missing middle” housing movement aimed at
persuading localities to relax their zoning straight-jacket.
HUD should provide models, not mandates, to help localities change course. Smart communities will see the advantage.
Should Washington override local zoning Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds.
And be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.